and joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line right now from the athletic
and stadium senior nba insider after
the bucks and warriors come up with the
season opening wins on season opening
night sham sharonia here on the rich
eisen show how are you doing shams
rich i'm good i'm glad the season's up
and started a lot going on around the
league as you know yes indeed let's do
let's do the league a little bit of a
favor and place the the sim and stuff
aside for the moment because we had
actual games last night we got actual
games coming up tonight um
how do you uh take the season opening
loss for the lakers do we have a major
problem brewing here in los angeles what
do you think
yeah i'm never one to make you know hot
take assumptions but i i do think it's
clear that they need to figure out how
this dynamic is gonna work right and
that's why you you saw russell westbrook
and we've done some reporting on as well
russell westbrook were brought in
anthony davis had to do a lot of you
know talking and and conversing before
the trade happened on draft night where
russell westbrook ended up with the
lakers because they need to figure out
if they could get on the same page and
at the end of the day it's going to take
a lot of sacrifice and it's going to
take a lot of these guys changing their
games and russell westbrook uh we saw
him try to slash a little [ __ ] you know
he he obviously did not shoot well from
the field
but we're gonna need to see him take uh
you know take more jumpers make more
jumpers this year playing alongside
lebron james and anthony lebron loves to
have shooters around him that's
something that he's preached year in and
year out and so to see how this team
comes together it will take time there's
no question but i don't know if you can
really judge them before they get to
that 15 20 game mark well i mean
westbrook's uh uniform number almost
matched the number of points he had in
the first half last night you know and
and
it is just odd to see
him out on the floor trying to fit in i
mean that's that's really what we're
looking at because the preseason hardly
hardly any time on the floor for all the
big three together so what is the plan
like is it just to him shoot and it's
just adding him to what lebron normally
does are we going to see some sort of
hybrid what are you hearing out of
lakers camp with what frank vogel's plan
is
to make this all work
yeah i think the goal was to have both
of those guys play off each other you
know as best as they can while they're
on the floor but also when lebron's off
the floor having the ability to have a
dynamic playmaker be in the game at any
point in time that's what the lakers
envisioned with dennis schroeder last
year is whenever lebron james went to
the bench having a de facto point guard
you've seen lebron james play a lot of
point guards since coming to la and
having another guy that can play that
position be dynamic make plays that's
what the lakers envisioned with
schroeder and now westbrook has that
mantle and so
seeing how he can take that in stride
when lebron is on the bench i think
that's the best case scenario but when
they're on the floor together they need
to find a way to compete and win uh so
that plus minus isn't in the negatives
okay and uh what'd you make of the
warriors game last night um they looked
pretty sharp moving the ball around and
making shots
even when steph wasn't he still wound up
with his first triple double and in five
years and clay isn't even back yet what
do you think about the warriors
i mean i i love the way that jordan pull
we saw in his first couple seasons he
just did not gain much traction um and
you could tell at the tail end of last
year he started to find his stride but
there were questions on whether they
were going to pick up his third year
rookie option and the warriors ended up
picking it up and
the entire preseason he played at such a
high level um i'm curious to see where
he fits in long term is he a sixth man
down the line when klay thompson does
come back do they start him alongside
clay um but it's no question that he has
the potential to be a significant scorer
in this league and he's already proven
that
so seeing them go back to that ball
movement i think iguodala coming back uh
to the warriors was it was a step in
that direction and also having a healthy
draymond green you saw him go through
the ups and downs last year
he dealt with covid last year during
training camp james wiseman was out uh
to start the year and then and then he
came back for opening night so they're
really not dealing with those losses in
and out of the lineup you're seeing a
steady group and now come december
january they're going to have klay
thompson and james wiseman back in that
lineup sham cheranya of the athletican
stadium right here on the rich eisen
show and the bucks and the nets um last
night what's your takeaway from game one
between the world champs and the
would-be potential world champs this
year
yeah i mean i think milwaukee picked up
right where they left off even though
drew hardy got hurt but you know overall
the nets we know are gonna be a dynamic
offensive team you saw even last night
kevin durant clearly
you know continues to prove that he's
one of the best players it's not
definitely the best scorer in the league
and patty mills the way he shot the ball
but seeing where they can get production
from their front court especially you
saw claxton having their double double
but you know lamarcus aldridge paul
millsap blake griffin those are the guys
that we need to step up and then
speaking of people around the
organization last night it was clear
that they believed that those guys
especially will need a few games you
know 10 15 games to find a rhythm into
the season uh this is a veteran group
just like the lakers they're not a team
that has a bunch of young pups uh
playing in their starting rotation they
have cam thomas who can come off the
bench and light it up but for the most
part this is a veteran-laden group so i
think it will take them time to find
their stride and figuring out will kyrie
irving join this roster oh but it's
clear that the bucks have picked up
right where they left off now that's the
question shams because um you know the
nets have
turned the page which is a phrase that
you hear so much in
in sports but then there's another
phrase you hear in sports is keeping
tabs we're going to keep tabs on that
person you hear that with the seahawks
this week with cam newton we're going to
keep tabs on them i don't know what that
means keeping tabs either you're going
to sign the guy or you are not you know
so what what is the status and how much
should we be paying attention to that
question about will kyrie join the nets
sure i mean rich
it's it's one of the best players on a
championship favorite that is basically
not playing this season and deciding to
sit the season this is unprecedented
there's something that's never happened
this week before and obviously this is a
big loss for the next they've decided
that he is not going to be present four
games they put their foot down uh even
though he is eligible to practice at
home even though he is
able to play on the road he was able to
play last night they just decided that
they are not playing him they're going
to pay him half of his salary this year
which is about roughly 16 17 million but
he's not going to get the other half uh
and by virtue he's not going to get an
extension as well and so for kyrie
irving this is a significant financial
loss um for his personal individual
decision that he's making to not get
vaccinated so um as of right now i i'm
in touch with city hall on a daily basis
there's no plans in the in the anywhere
near future to lift that vaccine mandate
in new york city so for now kyrie irving
will continue to sit until either he
decides to get the vaccine or the
mandates lifted or he's traded um those
are the only scenarios that i see him
playing this season because as of right
now um
there's just is not an avenue for him to
return to the net yeah mandate's not
mandated mandate's not being lifted i
mean that that that's definitely not
happening but you know before the uh
before the nba finals uh you i just
don't see the way that this pandemic you
know anybody who pays attention to
you know the health news
and certainly what's going on in new
york city unless curtis sliwa becomes
the new mayor of new york city uh
honestly like that would be the only way
that that happens with an election
that's coming around and we don't see it
and that allows also
adam silver to say this is this is not a
league matter it's a it's a city matter
and it's a team matter so the question
is is how how does it change with with
kyrie right i mean
do you do you keep tabs do you
every now and then knock on the door of
his of
of his uh
camp the people who said that he's
giving voice to the voiceless in your
reporting sam yeah i i haven't i haven't
gotten a sense either way on whether
there's there's any opening for him to
go get the vaccine i mean as i reported
last week there's as of right now
there's no plans for him to get
vaccinated so in turn that means there's
no plans for him to play uh any time now
could kyrie irving at any point within
the next two weeks or whenever you know
whenever he decides in a day or
really it could be any point you can
wake up and say i want to get the shot
and then he'll show up for practice or a
game so the nets will welcome him back
but as of right now there just is not a
timeline now the one thing that even
kyrie irving came on and said last week
because he wants to play basketball he
loves the game there's no plans for
retire well
his love for the game is definitely
going to be tested here over the next
several weeks as he watches the next
play game in the gate game out and not
be on the floor with them and was his
instagram story um posting was that
giving voice to the voiceless i i know
that sounds facetious but i'm i'm
serious like what
what what is his plan to actually put
into action what he
feels that he's standing for
yeah i mean yeah i mean you you would
you would have thought that there might
have been kind of like you said like a
plan afterward right because you you
want to stand up for people you know in
his mind if he wants to stand up for
people that have lost their jobs
uh what you know what's the action
that's also being taken place and so i
haven't there's been nothing on my end
that that's able to report on all right
champs gerania the athletic and stadium
right here on the rich eisen show your
latest in the athletic um the headline
ben simmons and sixers at odds again
what's been going on at practices and
what's next for both sides i'll bite
certainly since he will be sitting out
tonight's
season opener for the sixers in
new orleans and barring anything else
his first game where he'll be back is in
philadelphia at home against the nets
coming up this weekend on friday night
so
let's start with what's been going on at
practices shams what is yeah rich not
much i mean you know it's a lot of
coming in in the facility and leaving uh
promptly whenever he's allowed to i mean
he's the first one
out of each practice there's not much
interaction with there hasn't been that
much interaction with teammates sunday
monday and obviously it was a short
stint for him yesterday uh when he
didn't
want to get into a defensive drill but
it's been a lot of you know really
coming and going uh rich he hasn't been
showering at the facility i'm told um
he's been coming in changing his clothes
and leaving and you you're seeing a guy
that is really going through the motions
he doesn't seem like he's mentally
engaged with his with the team with his
teammates he's done a few drills uh
defensively uh nothing more nothing less
and so you know speaking of people
around that organization people that
have been at those practices this you
know the last three days they say that
he's a guy that does not look like he's
planning on playing in the near future
and so clearly that is not tonight in
the season opener i don't know if
that'll be friday um you know from what
i've been told they're gonna welcome him
back at practice tentatively scheduled
for thursday so we'll see if he goes to
practice and if he does how he behaves
and how he handles himself um you know
in his mind he's not mentally there yet
to join a team where he felt like doc
river joel embiid threw him under the
bus after game seven and just does not
believe that you know they mended their
fences and so now it's just about
figuring out can they reach a middle
ground where he can get back on the
floor because the quicker he gets back
on the floor you know from from people
in philadelphia to tell me the quicker
he might be able to get moved because
he's able to play and and pour his heart
out there and until he does that i just
don't see
any type of trade aspect uh going on
right now you know as i reported
last night there just is not a deal that
philly's looking at right now they're
not trying to move ben simmons so this
is going to be a stalemate for the
foreseeable future yeah that's a that's
that's the point shams is that
somebody's got to tell him that if he
wants out
he not only has to you know act like
he's in
for
the ability for the sixers to feel
compelled to get him
for more than sense on the dollar
right and also to make sure that there's
nobody else around the league saying
why wouldn't this happen to us if we
acquire him like there but for the grace
of god
basketball gods go us right i mean like
is there anybody in his camp explaining
that time
to him
yeah i mean i i think that this is just
scenario where the player is so dead set
on not wanting to be with this franchise
and he's made it clear to them over and
over he's not mentally there to play for
them um but the fact remains is that
there's not a deal that's on the table
that they would do there's really
nothing in these in the imminent future
and he's got four years and almost 150
million left on his deal it's
unprecedented for a player with that
much length on his contract to try to
get out i mean you've seen players with
one or two years left but for four years
left it's just um i know you know
clearly philadelphia has support of of
the league and everyone all the other
rival teams because they don't want to
be
made an example of they want to be the
ones that are making the example out of
the player and so you're seeing kind of
do two different sides two different
agendas here at playoffs ben simmons
wants a move and philadelphia wants him
back on the floor because as of right
now he's their best
option to go win games um but i think
teams around the league understand that
ben simmons has always been professional
one thing about him is you know unless
he's hurt he's going to be on the floor
he's going to be playing he's going to
be trying to play at a high level um and
so he just
right now this is not a situation that
he wants to play at a high level for so
then can they keep on
um suspending him because as you point
out in your article he's lost uploads of
a million dollars in fine money for
missing preseason games practices and
team activities so far your our
colleague at uh the worldwide leader woj
saying is he he hasn't made a dime since
he's returned that they're so can the
sixers keep doing that are they allowed
under the cba
uh to keep doing what they did just for
game one
yeah i mean i i definitely you know as
long as they feel like he continues to
have contact detrimental to the team
they can continue whether it's find him
or suspend him and i think that next
test case will come on thursday when he
returns to practice you know if they end
up going through with the practice on
thursday after the game tonight that how
does he show what's his disposition and
they're hoping that he turns the pages
and that he shows
you know some some energy some signs of
wanting to be there so they can move
forward all right last one for you shams
i i if you don't mind uh i gave this
assignment also to sam amick your
colleague at the athletics so i'll
create some in-house competition can you
find out where simmons got those
sweatpants
can you who's whose sweatpants are those
that he wore the other day in practice
with the cell phone sticking out can you
find that out for me shams would you
please yeah i haven't i have no idea but
i hate to to break it that wasn't a cell
phone in his pants that was actually um
that was actually another jersey that he
had probably
wanted these players to wear during
practice and uh he left it in his
in his in his pants and not putting it
on okay so that's that was not a cell
phone in his pocket that was not a cell
phone that was a jersey
oh
okay see you know i guess this is a
lesson for us to learn that we we take a
photograph and we make much of it
and so that was not a cell phone it was
another jersey in his
my gosh i mean that's a lot that that's
those sweatpants can hold a lot so that
then i definitely want the i want the
sweatpants for me if they can hold a
jersey i want
you know that's impressive okay there
you go
man oh man jersey and sweatpants
reporting that's that's exactly what i'm
hearing but i'll tell you what though
shams that's that's him that's actually
important because the number of people
have thought that was a cell phone and
he's just like shane i'm not even i'll
show you how i don't care about
practicing i'll i'll text during during
drill you know what i mean so i've been
on this phone a lot at the facility but
not in that instance not in that
specific drill all right shams thanks
very much really appreciate the time
always appreciate your reporting and
your time right here and let's uh let's
chat uh throughout the season i really
appreciate it
always rich appreciate you man you gotta
that's sham sharania of the athletic and
stadium and sham sharonia uh it's that's
his twitter handle and at shams nba on
instagram right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here